[Music]
[Applause]
this week we've got blind surfer nurse
arrest and love note take it away
yeah breakfast sorry there's this 24
year old named Derek who is from Brazil
and he is completely blind but he is a
pro surfer whoa no fear like a piece of
[ __ ] but not to be like naked in Malaya
how does he like find his way to shore
what if he tells the wrong way I know I
was thinking the same so he does have
help to get them but God where he needs
to be yeah cause like what if he gets
caught in the Riptide yeah and he gets
off somebody help him out please Sena
don't disable him like that how does he
know the waves are coming I'm so he said
that he feels the ocean wow it's a
superhero that's true you could you
could kind of feel the current and
everything yeah he says that every
single part of a wave feels different
and it sounds different so he's able to
it's a superhero
yes heightened senses yeah he's
daredevil
she's like a dolphin oh yeah dolphin
echolocator [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
you know there's do we do our article
where people were learning how to
echolocate that blind kid that
rollerblades
yeah all he does is just click yeah yeah
he was and it's like he bounces off he
was born blind and he's handsome as [ __ ]
do his Isaac live they can see it'll do
it's it's uh it's it's what storm
it's what's his name the bread bran
stark but oh yeah it's oh yeah none of
you guys watch Game of Thrones no you
exemplary I've never seen one episode
see you don't like it I don't like it
good man even mentioned Gaiman so it
sucks for him because like he's a really
good-looking man but he doesn't even
know it he's beautiful he's athletic all
question which that's to even I can't
even see and he could I mean I could see
and he can't and I can't even surf that
good yeah so he's actually conquered the
pipeline in Hawaii maybe having eyes is
is it yeah because it scares the [ __ ]
cuz all he does is just feel it is he a
sponsored athlete like yeah
you've been surfing next to the great
surfers of our time right now that's so
cool really cool yeah have you tried
surfing yeah we learn how to surf in
Hawaii ah terrifying I can't even do
waves like that just scares the [ __ ] out
of me you're half the battle is like
it's it's it's just Irish you know we
handling your way out yeah yeah we were
when we were learning I serve and they
kept pushing the surfboard to help us
you know like wasn't that bad and then
they stopped pushing us I like who you
[ __ ] can't even move to catching the
catch the wave you got a really paddle
to do fun things in life you have to be
physically fit yeah that's what sucks
[ __ ] bird arms you know just there's
so many things I want to do really well
but it requires me to work on my
physical prowess no but it's pretty
doggone daring I know my dad that looks
fun but it's not gonna be fun when I do
it
yeah it's all like the fit people are
just gliding and I'm like like weird
situations like that I want to put you
on Oh indoor skydiving I want to see
that see I there's a lot things I want
to do but it just requires me to get
paid for it you don't need to be fit for
indoor skies turn it up turn it up what
are those lagers
it feels pretty crazy though cuz me and
Bart got to do it for a video and it
just feels like you're weightless but
there's constant pressure going like mmm
up this way and the slightest movements
kind of painful yeah like it's pretty
crazy actually like the like the
equipment like the Olympics of that and
they're [ __ ] amazing yeah they do
like flips they run up yeah well the guy
that works there was doing all that kind
of [ __ ] huh I'm so physically unfit I
can't do [ __ ] I would look at things oh
my god it's really cool you know I want
to try it and then I find out requires a
lot of cardio [ __ ] it really does that
want to try fencing I want to look a
beekeeper just do it that's just a lot
of goryeo where the [ __ ] can you find
fencing there's a lot thank you I've
never seen like a fencing
store get out of a the [ __ ] you get
the
it's like fighting beekeepers how do
they do it without stabbing each other
yeah and how do you see through that
catches it right yeah I mean do you get
injuries though is it like karate and
[ __ ] and you tap if you can tap your
buddy but you win like I think there
yeah but what if someone pushes too hard
it bends it bends so glad and my parents
didn't fence cuz that just means that's
just a new weapon for them they hit me
with their Naturals all [ __ ] bamboo
sticks everything dude have you guys
seen this new thing it's kind of like
it's like UFC but it's with Knights they
have like Wars like you have like ten on
ten if they do that - yeah it's like a
[ __ ] gladiator sword and a shield
yeah so cool you're in full armor I
don't know is it one-on-one or just like
group you could have both let's go JK
yeah they get people get like
concussions and like it's cool calm what
material is the no weapons like real
it's real milk yeah they get knocked in
the head so hard with like hammers and
swords that people knock ok got helmets
right yeah but there's injuries there's
like whatever even if you're wearing
full armor this is televised yeah that's
cool it's worldwide so yeah it's crazy
[ __ ] dude it's kind of like they have a
Renaissance Faire and then they have
these like full-contact like Wars and
[ __ ] yeah so it's not reenactments I've
never been to one of those Renaissance
shits it's fun is it you went to one
[ __ ] you know my friend dressed me up in
full like renaissance geared this past
year you asian wench oh no I was an
archer it's like a black cloak oh [ __ ]
you're a warrior yeah and then they've
been those guys they're like very into
it they go everything weird Yvonne
through the building nerds
Oh have you ever seen nip/tuck yeah
couple of do you remember that the Asian
guy that spoke French the hit man
no well it was him basically that's my
buddy and they go in full Templar
clothing like chainmail helmet it was
[ __ ] sick and they carried a big
treasure box full of jewels and candy
for the kids a little rapist realistic
you're a candy back then yeah dried beef
and stinky cheese in there take this dry
pine they like in full roleplay like do
they speack no like that the hordes are
coming me Lord well if you want to be
like historically accurate we should all
go in with samurai armor overalls imma
build a railroad like just and then
Bucky no good so if it's like one of
those Western reenactments gonna make
money for our next story there was this
nurse that got arrested for doing her oh
I'm so jealous I'm so jealous of people
like this why because she can make
millions now I don't want the cops to
[ __ ] arrest me to arrest me man
number one said when I was at United I
wanted to hit me sorry it takes place in
Salt Lake City Utah
God why can't the police held assault me
I want money man just [ __ ] punch me
in the face one we can't make that
happen right now girl you get flown out
around the world but I'm not gonna do
man millions off of one court case I bet
you I bet you what they did they did
out-of-court settlement probably no way
she wasn't taking him and she wasn't
charging them with didn t that's why
been doing an out of court settlement
yeah oh yeah so it's off the books yeah
so it happened here there was a suspect
named Marcos 26 years old he was fleeing
from the police and he
that uh crossing into oncoming traffic
on a freeway this guy sounds really my
foot in a car or in a car I really like
the work they were doing my car chase
right through that makes s yeah so then
he ends up crossing into oncoming
traffic he hits head-on he crashed his
head-on with a truck driver named
William 43 years old and Marco he died
so will you die yeah he died and so
William he ended up going to the
hospital he's in a coma
using the burn unit could you go back
yeah because once they hit head on it
was like an explosion what's this a
[ __ ] Michael Bay movie pretty much so
then Williams in a coma the police go to
the hospital and they're trying to get a
blood sample and that's when this nurse
Alex she ends up saying that there's
only three situations that would allow
them to draw blood for the police and
that would be if the patient is under
arrest or if they have a warrant or if
the patient is able to give consent
right but he's in a coma so yeah but you
can't and why would they need to draw
blood if this patient isn't the suspect
or anything
he's the accident victim exactly so
that's what makes no sense because this
detective detective Jeff Payne is the
one handed up arresting this nurse
because it escalated set point but he
ends up saying that he wanted they
wanted to draw blood to protect the
victim not punish him which makes no
[ __ ] sense regardless they still need
consent exactly never watch Law & Order
SVU [ __ ] its SUV yes sir then anyways
they ended up getting like the nurse she
ended up calling her supervisor she has
him on speaker telling the detective
like look we can we can't I can't give
you blood without one of these three
three things happening right so then
that's when the detective got frustrated
he ended up arresting the nurse and I
have a video clip period for what
obstructing he was a power trip he was
who was recording it somebody else was
someone that was mine and it was also
the body cam footage from yeah oh my
goodness for body cam yeah
and so I'm going to show you guys this
clip and she ended up being in the
police car for 20 minutes and then she
was released without charge but it was
just a whole scene and this is also in
the patient care unit like the patients
are so crazy so here we're standing her
ground yeah she she did an amazing job
he's so aggressive
who's mad Wow his cops don't like to be
wrong it's not even a threat and then
she's saying sir you're hurting me he's
like then just walk then you're not
treating her like [ __ ] yeah he was just
power tripping me somebody told him no
oh so let me guess he's not even like in
trouble maybe paid leave
I think he's not fired really that's the
first time I've ever heard he was placed
on administrative leave and ministry
there was a I think something recently
popped up fired from his part-time
paramedic job how the [ __ ] is this guy a
person of the community he's a cop and a
paramedic but he obviously abuses his
power that's the first time he was
caught on camera imagine what he's like
when the cameras off must have beat a
lot of people mm-hmm so then now the
hospital has placed new restrictions on
officers entering patient care area hell
yeah they should do that who uh like
where is this it's not Lake City Utah
Utah you told a nice place to have been
there I heard there's a lot of what
Mormons marma isn't you taught a place
with that that's salt bed Lake whatever
what Salt Lake Salt Lake ha ha no but
then like when it rains it looks like a
mirror like when you stand there's not a
Utah Jazz are there yeah that's about it
and Sundance I sure like this happened
to me man there's that one lady that got
arrested because she's you want [ __ ]
like that to happen to you but it scared
it's fine I'll be scared for 20 minutes
just get millions this is one lady they
got a rest because you're immediately
going I'm getting rich oh yeah
and you're not gonna get anything from
the cops stupid that if you can never
get money for it so hard you got to get
like McDonald's the [ __ ] sticks
french fries in your [ __ ] or something
dude i called french fries there's this
one lady that she got arrested because a
cash register didn't believe that two
dollar bills
exist and thought it was faked so cops
on her it was a little girl oh really
that one time i was in a little girl
stupid though that's suppose to be good
luck you not supposed to give away to
you never use your - oh grandma or
someone gave it to me to have any other
movie i see that's why you got arrested
bad luck this is one story i went to and
they sell skateboards and there's just
one on the floor I was just like hmm if
I were to slip I'm afraid of breaking
bones I don't want to do it no I
wouldn't want to do that though because
it's too painful you know not because
it's wrong oh is it wrong no I'm it's a
skateboard shop come on you got to go
for the big ones the evil corporations
true true like which one's McDonald's
yeah man I'm not sure about the customer
service or whatever but that shit's
[ __ ] dope got cheap everything dude I
like Target but they're too expensive
sometimes man yeah they got more more
commercials like Walmart's the last time
I think target is one of those it's like
you trying to be bougie but everyone
knows you a discount store fool why you
lying for last story this little old
lady and Thea is her name Pia and Thea
it's pretty
69 years old she is auctioning off a
treasured love letter from Jim Jimi
Hendrix that she received back in 1967
Wow Hendrix no she didn't sleep with him
so what happened the story is that Wow
you got a love letter and you didn't
[ __ ] him I want a love letter Frenchy
right hand
it's just up there it's like a big lad
that's it
no come here platings like you owe me
some money it was like a tab no so the
story is that Jimi Hendrix he was gonna
be playing a show with this other band
that her boyfriend was a part of so then
she was there watching them and
apparently she was the only girl in the
room at that time and that's when
Hendrix just walks over to her they
start talking she says that she was so
nervous that she doesn't remember at all
what the conversation was about but that
he ended up going back and telling like
the band mate telling the bed mates like
Oh is there anything for me to write on
so then they ended up giving him a
packet of guitar strings and so he ended
up writing this note for her that says
to Anthea
love and kisses to you forever I wish I
could really talk to you and it's like
underline stay sweets Jimi Hendrix also
he was hitting on his bandmates girl who
you know it wasn't bad man
opening band he's featured on this other
band this particular concert oh what a
douchebag [ __ ] new that's being
auctioned off she says that they're
estimating that she can get about 3,000
that's it keep it's on a shirt some
scribbles of leaves fronds you're
looking at her sure you're not looking
at the harbor no I look like her shirt
hat autographs all over it only 3,000
that sucks yeah I'd rather just keep it
50 years yeah she says like throughout
time she always like cherished and she
planted a little frame and stuff because
her boyfriend ended up telling her at
that time like oh you should keep it
even though he got a little jealous
that's a good boyfriend for
understanding the certainty yeah if I
was a boyfriend and like I don't know
let's say like the rock like hit hit on
like Muriel right and then wrote her a
love note I'm like yeah you know put it
next to our bed stencil I can look at it
I would because then every time someone
comes over hey you know what my
girlfriend she's a groupie so she was 19
what this happens this is around that
time 1990 it's not a 19 year old pic
dude she's like a solid like that's a 30
rs30 you can smoke a lot of cigarettes
that's why so the same why does she look
younger than ya a nice lady I mean
they're calling it a love letter and I
really know people looked so old like
back in a day when they were young cuz
my grandma still look like a grandma
when she was in high school that's so
true like in the history books and like
I'm looking at like you know you you
ulysses s grant or whatever i'm like
looking at his pictures 225 years old he
looks like a [ __ ] like freakin
teenagers that are 12 oh they look older
than me their makeup I know how are you
gonna look like a 12 year old hooker
great what age would you let your
daughter start putting on makeup 13 oh
[ __ ] I think that's a real question for
you I figured it out the other day even
though I don't got a daughter it's gonna
be and starting towards the summer of
eighth grade before she hits high school
so you could be a little [ __ ] scrub
in junior high the high school you got
to be a bad [ __ ] so during the
summertime that's when you get the
practice from nation you know I mean I
don't want her to look like a [ __ ]
trying to figure out herself but even
then it's not even like heaven make it
just maybe like lip gloss yeah that's it
I think I already lost just having Gina
as a friend sure part within the first
year shouldn't put makeup on my big
mouth yeah these are dildos
these are dad
get away from our I'm gonna fire the
go-go boots
little tiny freak you know yeah yeah
I'll get them like chapstick you know
when they're young like tinted chapstick
let them do their hair you know cuz I
can't head to the girl frizzy and [ __ ]
but you know I'll talk about like
foundation blush all the other [ __ ] you
gotta you gotta ease into that [ __ ] you
glow BB cream have to go I'm sorry
that's cool BB cream man I can't imagine
my daughter having good hygiene stinky
girl
I mean her name is paperclip with you oh
my god that'd be so dumb paper getting
paper oh I would love to scream goddamn
sure I I think like ever it's so weird
because teenager now and teenagers now
are not going through that but awkward
face yeah they skip it yeah because now
they have all these makeup to do
internet internet changed a 14-8
I miss bullying dude book hey you guys
want to stock any of us we'll go ahead
down to the description box below and
you can follow us on Instagram and all
kinds of stuff for more videos
[Music]